was ich gleich zeige ist die
beispielhafte desinfektion einer tür die
tür und der türgriff als keimzelle sie
würden mal davon ausgehen im privaten
sowie als auch im öffentlichen bereich
spielt gar keine rolle
das wird immer gleich gehandhabt also
der erste schritt ist natürlich erstmal
der eigenschutz der eigenschutz jetzt
nicht zwangsläufig auch die keime aber
der eigenschutz als solches gegen
desinfektionsmittel gegenüber wir
arbeiten täglich mit diesen präparaten
und wir haben natürlich in ihre
anwendungen auch ein gewisses
gefährdungspotenzial für die gesundheit
der bedarf im moment ist riesig also wir
müssen ganz viele andere sachen in
unserem spezial reinigungstechnik nach
hinten schieben müssen das verschieben
oder teilweise absagen um einfach diesen
corona bedarf gerecht zu werden also der
arbeitsschutz wird angelegt handschuhe
anzug schutz augenschutz mit brille und
ein arten filterelemente und im
anschluss daran wird desinfektionsmittel
in sprühflasche eingefüllt ein
spezieller fliesst lappen getränkt also
im grundsatz ist so dass man natürlich
erstmal abklären müssen was ist das
problem in dem fall sehr wahrscheinlich
corona bestätigt der verdachtsfall und
dementsprechend würde man dann fragen wo
hat sich der mitarbeiter aufgehalten um
mit dem auftraggeber zu besprechen
welche flächen als solches tatsächlich
desinfiziert werden sollen zum beispiel
bei bürogebäuden mit mehreren
stockwerken ist die verschleppung
gefahren problem gewesen ja oder nein
und wenn ja dann die empfehlung zum
beispiel darauf dass das gesamte gebäude
einmal komplett desinfiziert wird
oberfläche
auf der tür ein gespräch mit dem
desinfektionsmittel auf geteilten 13
und zwar der obere tat sprechen bereich
des rahmens oder der tür fläche der
griff als solches und dann sag ich immer
noch mal die kinder zone weil die wird
glaube ich oftmals vernachlässigt und
vergessen
aber auch die kleinen tatschen natürlich
an diesen flächen und gerade die und da
ist es besonders wichtig dass man da
keine kein verschleppungen in den
häuslichen bereich oder wohin auch immer
dann dadurch praktiziert es wird bei uns
so ausgelegt dass bei desinfektions
gewinnen so eine desinfektionsmaßnahmen
anhand der ober positive dessen beziehen
und dann hat der verfahrensweise mit dem
notwendigen personal ein arbeitstag
benötigt wird
ja das ist auch ein bisschen abhängig
von der oberflächen konditionierung und
den eingesetzten desinfektionsmitteln
und im anschluss nach unserer
desinfektion ist lüftungs prozess
vorgesehen und dann kann man zwei
stunden später wieder das büro ganz
normal benutzen